and as we remember our President George
HW Bush this morning this is a view of
the house where he lived in New Haven
Connecticut with his wife Barbara more
than seventy years ago remember mr. Bush
was then a student at Yale University
married to Barbara he enrolled after
World War 2 and graduated then in 1948
the couple went on to have six children
17 grandchildren and eight
great-grandchildren we sat down with
Loren and Pierce Bush they are children
of the former president's third son Neil
and like their grandfather both have
committed themselves to public service
Loren Bush Loren founded feed a company
dedicated to fighting world hunger
Pierce Bush is CEO of Big Brothers Big
Sisters lone Starr in Texas the
organization's largest affiliate he was
in the room when his grandfather died on
Friday I know you were with him in his
final moments how was it's just really
peaceful and it was so clear to me Nora
there was just a moment a five-second
moment and it was so clear that his soul
had left his body and his you know my
grandfather gampy as we call him was no
longer there and there was no doubt in
my mind that he was up in heaven being
United with his maker and obviously
being reunited with our grandmother
Danny and his daughter Robin and other
loved ones it was really just a really
peaceful peaceful moment he said in a
letter in 1984 it's a funny thing when
you get older even if you have an
exciting life surrounded by interesting
people and having a chance to meet all
the world leaders even with all that
what counts is family and love we love
you already
more than tongue can tell yeah I think
that says it all I mean you know he
lived that exciting life surrounded by
world leaders and had really interesting
jobs and and yet he was very much
grounded in his family and in the sense
of love and kindness for those around
him and that was true that's not lip
service you once got a very important
letter from him with
after you got into some big trouble
right yes yes when I just graduated from
college and I I wrecked is I wrecked his
boat on the rocks in a very gentle way
which led his fidelity his famous boat
the next night I also got a lashing from
my grandmother who showed more she was
always loving but showed more of a tough
love than my grandfather and I could see
in his eyes he could feel how you know
embarrassed I was how sensitive you know
the grandmothers were kind of hitting me
and that evening when I went to dinner
and I came back home there's this
amazing note and it was addressed on the
envelope it said you know - my main man
Pierce I just remember walking upstairs
in the big house and just followed right
what I saw note first of all for my
grandfather to make it upstairs it was
really hard at that time but then the
note was just so typical of gampy it
said you know Pierce I remember days
when I could do no no right but then I
would go to bed and the next day the son
would embrace me and all would be okay
you're a good man you got a bad bounce
always always okay life goes on I love
you more than Duncan tell something like
that I mean Danny does to Gabby and it
was just one of those notes almost
thankful that the boat incident happened
so that you can treasure that because
it's so valuable knew that you you just
needed that encouragement you'll bounce
back totally totally 100% what do you
hope the country learns from the life he
lived I think you know he his big line
as president was a kinder gentler nation
and I do think that is what it boils
down to that's what he wanted for this
country it's what he wanted for
relationships and the world is a kinder
gentler world father would want a kinder
gentler world a really important more
kindness in the world is kind of a part
thought that they hope people think
about their fair grandfather today
Pierce's story got to menorah
because what to be able to do that when
you're feeling horrible about something
and someone telling you know you're a
good person it's okay after you wreck
your father's boat it does it means
everything yeah Lauren in Pierce I
should also tell you I asked them about
their grandfather's famous sock
collection yeah the socks right and you
can see the the former presidents ankles
when he began you know sitting in the
wheelchair and so they say he did that
because he wanted to add a little color
and levity and they also told me he now
has probably the biggest sock collection
in the world so I'll see more of that
soon and I love the socks he's wearing
today they've been showing the socks
flying in formation and that line you've
got a bad bounce yeah you know and that
you can bounce back from a bad bounce
and you're still loved you're not a bad
person even though you've done something
that sort of ticked everybody off you're
still loved important message to send
and just at one point that only tongue
can tell that message he would sign on
those notes that is what his
three-year-old daughter when she died
with three of leukemia those are
reportedly the last words she said to
her father and today on the CBS this
morning podcast you can hear our full
twenty minute conversation with Lauren
Bush Lauren and Pierce Bush